good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
extremely early because I have to go to
the dentist this morning to find out if
I need a root canal spoiler alert
probably so like I'm coming to you today
wearing a suit and a holden caulfield
hat because it's time for the bank of
nerdfighteria z' quarterly report which
is more of an annual report these days
but with the project for awesome coming
up it's important so like the Bank of
nerdfighteria is like Charlie McDonnell
it has two arms also it's so nice and
generous and talented and handsome right
so first we have the giving arm the
foundation to decrease worldsuck was
originally set up in 2007 to do a
mixture of things like sending
nerdfighters to their first concerts and
like trying to address global poverty
well it since 2008 we've been more
focused on like the global poverty end
of the spectrum because you know it's
more important after last year's project
for awesome the foundation to decrease
worldsuck donated more than eighty
thousand dollars to five charities
chosen by the YouTube community which is
awesome except it means that after that
we were broke since then we've been
refilling the coffers this year we have
fifteen thousand dollars currently in
the bank plus an additional sixty
thousand dollars in pledges so it should
be bigger than last year now to the
lending arm oh but I should mention
minecraft area one of the reasons that
we have $15,000 is because of the
nerdfighter minecraft server which makes
me think about something important but I
have to go to the dentist so you are
coming to you didn't think you were
going to the dentist today but you were
wrong Shh do you hear that Hank no you
don't because it's electric bug you will
get will you will your fight area used
to be a YouTube based phenomenon but now
there are so many places to be a
nerdfighter there's minecraft area
there's the adult nerdfighter group on
Facebook countless location-specific
Facebook groups
there's the nerdfighters of the Ning and
of the new forum our pants the
nerdfighters subreddit on reddit the
nerdfighters vu group then there's the
fu hundred fighters tumblr and tumblr
more generally and there are probably
tons of others I don't even know about
and then there are the nerdfighters of
Kiva no root canal yet no you would come
through for me people hunting hat
alright let's talk about Kiva
Keef is a website that allows regular
people to make loans to entrepreneurs in
the developing world giving those
businesspeople access to banking which
otherwise they wouldn't have when we
last checked in with the nerdfighter
keeper group they had just passed 1
million dollars in loans and right now
we are about to pass 1.6 million dollars
as you can see as you
as you can see here in our total amount
alone we're on a roller coaster that
only goes up but the coolest thing about
Kiva is that if you aren't a member yet
right now you can click the link in the
doobly-doo and you could make your first
loan for free not only that but the
person who invites you also gets to make
a free loan which in this case is Paul a
nerdfighter from Arizona who won a
raffle but in the past that person has
often been me which is why I've been
able to learn more than $64,000 so
having made more than 2,000 Keitha loans
what percentage of those people have so
far paid me back 100% heck I've loaned
sixty four thousand seven hundred and
seventy five dollars and so far I've
lost seven dollars due to currency
fluctuations in South Sudan I got to
help sixty four thousand dollars worth
of businesses around the world grow and
it cost me seven dollars so Hank that's
my report the lending arm is going like
gangbusters and the giving arm is ready
for the project for awesome so as I said
before there are now so many places to
be a nerdfighter that the project for
awesome isn't just a YouTube thing
anymore it's an internet thing but
YouTube is still the core of it so
nerdfighters make a video about a
charity you feel passionately about
uploaded on Monday at noon Eastern
hangout we'll see you on Friday
he sounds like a dental drill